you guys are gonna stop
[Music]
in theory of our relationship yeah but
the first time I met you was on a red
carpet for inside out I believe and we
we spoke about Star Wars a great deal
and we've been friends ever since when
you found out you were doing the show
what was your reaction and who was the
first person you told oh wow I was very
excited I was more excited when I found
out what the character's name was yeah I
want to get to that uh I didn't tell
anyone I kept it to myself how does
anybody do that ever because I was so
hard I mean we've had we've hung out
recently we've had dinner together
recently and I've known this and wasn't
able to tell you and you're want you're
a person in my life that I would tell
all of this to so it's hard it's crazy I
think I I think my wife and I told my
wife but I think she just differs like
why are you crying but but my god that's
the hardest part was I mean almost a
year yeah a little over a year I've
known now or least III started audition
for this a long time ago and I went in a
bunch with the people and like so it's
it's been around for a bit and to
finally be able to talk about it it's
just the best my wife didn't know that I
was doing Star Wars and I was while we
were recording she I just kept giving
her the codename of the show and she
thought wow you this you're so excited
about this little code name I can't get
me to go but so excited about this code
name like yeah and then when a couple of
weeks before they announced that we were
gonna be in the show I told her and she
was like you gotta feel like the best
man on the planet I feel great when when
she found out that he wrote the
character specifically for Mia he told
me about that and I was pretty blown
away that means that that really special
yeah see that's what I wanted to know
when I when I read your character's name
which is typeface type Faison
I was like did he did you negotiate that
was gonna be the name like I have no I
mean negotiate with Lucas I don't know I
have no idea this a luck it's kind of a
Star Wars name I mean it's a Star Wars
name face on your face there's gonna be
no Moynahan that's in the Star Wars
universe there could be a hype face-off
correct yeah so they're like we have a
character for you and his name is
highteeeee Basel yeah no I was cool yeah
totally chill yeah that's only my name
in order for the rest of my life did you
guys have that like I'm in a Star Wars
moment cuz I know like all the actors
have that onset was our moment in the vo
before you're like oh my god I keep
having that moment yeah right now yeah
it's that it's looking over your
shoulder and seeing that that logo you
keep you just crazy recording to like I
do a couple of other voices on the show
also and like every time you do a new
one you're like I'm gonna do like in my
mind like those tiny characters that you
know like everyone loves the tiny
character that one or just some crazy
name and like I could you could end up
being one of those you know you could
get one line in a Star Wars cartoon in
30 years from now there could be books
about it and it could become this
amazing thing so anything anything is
like a Star Wars a lottery ticket for me
went when I when I walk in there but
it's not I play Darth Vader I play Orca
Jim rash plays flicks we are flicks an
orca we work at the the acquisitions
store on the platform called the
Colossus we're kind of in the basement
these these little guys were a Bert and
Ernie type kind of the r2d2 and c3po of
this you know at least attitude wise of
the show and flicks is a bird-like
creature with them with long legs and
big eyes and he he's the brains of the
group he's a smart one a little
sarcastic a you know sardonic and I am
I'm work I'm just a a blue-collar little
pig man trying to try to make a buck and
and trying to get the best deal on
anything and he's a he's a wheeler and a
dealer and he you go to him when you
need something but he's also a good guy
you can trust him
yeah but he eats this space for things
that they think works Lords
not Borg's not ports not boards being
God by the way I need you to start the
gorg the gorg rebel I'm I'm happy - I'm
happy
that's right you're a yeah that's right
you're famous for knowing poor when he
just realized the poor lady crazy poor
lady please please become gorg later
anyway enough about me
I play hide Faison he is an ace pilot on
the platform the Aces act as the
security for the platform but when
they're you know in the middle of their
downtime they race each other and types
the fastest out of all of them I was
just telling him when I saw him when
they released that you know the the
video about the pilots recently I hadn't
seen his character yet and I didn't know
anything about it and I think it's one
of my favorite run designs and one of my
favorite attitudes for a character ever
it's like this guy would be Han Solo's
buddy you know well yeah he definitely
could kick it with honson yeah he's
definitely him and Chewie I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say hype Faison is probably
one of the best pilots in the galaxy
like that's asking me who's a better
pilot Han Solo opposed Evelyn you know
both of them you can take out him yeah
different different different guys for
different jobs did I say
well I mean I'm gonna go with the with
the
the originals and say that Han Solo's
and better pilot obvious hype faizon
play it safe
well that's the best way to play it you
know you don't want to get you summer
during online and nowadays you guys are
gonna stop the show
wait did you guys we did